when I first started to learn web
development I paid 400 for a CD of Adobe
Dreamweaver unlike the text editors we
use today what you see is what you get
wysiwigs have been around forever Visual
Basic for Windows came out 30 years ago
game developers write code by dragging
and dropping in tools like unreal and
mobile IDs like Android Studio always
keep the UI by your side but on the web
we choose to write most of our code with
a blindfold on I think this is due to
the challenge of responsive design
during the browser Wars but those days
are mostly behind us in today's video
we'll build an image Carousel inspired
by airbnb's website using a new visual
IDE called codex created by Wix the
sponsor of this video that brings drag
and drop productivity to react apps as a
stubborn web developer myself I was a
bit skeptical to try it but what I found
is that it can dramatically simplify
certain jobs and does so in a
non-invasive way one thing I've always
hated about visual tools is they tend to
create code that you don't understand
but that's not the case with codex it
works in tandem with vs code while
providing a robust visual layer on top
of your code it'll be easier if I just
show you so let's take a look at what
we're building today we have a
collection of cards for various airbnbs
which are made responsive with CSS grid
each card has its own collection of
images which can be rotated through by
clicking this button nothing too crazy
but the way we'll build this is like
nothing you've ever seen before when it
comes to react development the first
step is to download it from the website
and it's entirely free by the way then
create a new project you have the option
to import an existing project the only
requirement is that it uses typescript
and either CSS module SAS or stylable
for your styling the main thing I don't
like about this editor is that it only
supports react I would love a tool like
this for spelled view angular and so on
in any case I'm going to start from
scratch and go with the built-in Veet
template after it creates and installs
the dependencies you'll notice it
creates a board a board is just a
component itself that allows you to
isolate your own components very similar
to a tool like storybook if we go ahead
and click on a board that'll bring us
into the main editor down here at the
bottom it contains the code for that
board again it's just a component that
in this case renders the app component
there's a lot to talk about here but
first I want to back up back on the Home
tab you'll notice a few other icons here
in the bottom left corner like the file
explorer to look at the actual files in
this project which can be edited just
like you would in vs code with syntax
highlighting and code completion and
then you also have a full git
integration as well where you can easily
make and revert commits as needed what's
important to understand though is that
this is not trying to be a replacement
for vs code but rather it complements it
if we go back into the board you'll
notice this little menu here next to the
component that allows us to open it
directly in vs code looking closer at
the file structure you'll notice a
folder named codex this contains any
boards or templates that aren't part of
your main application there's also a
codex config file that can modify Its
Behavior but the cool thing is that
anything you edit in the project in vs
code will be instantly reflected in
codecs as you can see here I've got the
app component open but I want to get rid
of all this boilerplate as I go through
and delete elements and save the file
it's instantly updated in the Codex UI
but here's where things start to get fun
if we go into codecs and click on a
component it brings up the editor which
gives us a hierarchy of elements in the
Dom if we click on one and its bounding
box is highlighted in the UI which is
useful but we can also add new elements
to the Dom by clicking the add button
and that brings us an entire list of all
the possibilities personally I find this
extremely useful for building complex
forms because we can just drag and drop
all the form elements we need and
rearrange them which is far more
efficient than trying to do that in code
no matter how good you are in Bim then
on the other side of the screen
properties on any element can be
modified we can easily filter and update
them here and it will modify the code
automatically that's pretty cool but now
it's time to build our first react
component back in the home screen I'll
go ahead and click add followed by a new
component we'll give it a name of BNB
card which will represent our image
Carousel it's also worth noting that you
can create custom templates if you find
yourself implementing the same patterns
in multiple components once created
you'll notice back in the Home tab that
it also creates a new board for us which
allows us to develop this component in
isolation now go to the components and
click the pencil icon to bring up its
code notice how we have a typescript
interface here called BNB card props
when we add props to this in interface
we can automatically start using them in
codecs from the properties panel and
that's why it's required to use
typescript when using codecs for each
one of these cards we'll need a title a
price and an array of image URLs now go
back to the board and click on that
component and we can modify its props
right here to give it some dummy data to
build this card we'll first structure
out its elements delete the default text
then drop in a div below the root
that'll be our main card then inside
that div we have two other divs the
first one for the Carousel and the
second one for the main content below
the images now in the top div we can add
a dummy image for now and then in the
bottom div we can drag in a head in as
well as a paragraph and then we can
rearrange these elements as needed by
simply dragging and dropping and just
like that we have a basic card but it's
lacking in style luckily codex has an
awesome style editor which might be my
favorite feature of all go ahead and
click on the outer div then on the right
side you'll see a couple of other icons
computed Styles will give you a
breakdown of all the styles that
currently apply to that element this is
huge because I always find myself going
back and forth in the browser Dev tools
to look at computed Styles it's
extremely convenient to have this
information directly in your IDE now
click on the paintbrush to go to the
style editor click plus to add a new
class to this div and give it a name of
card that will add the card class to our
chosen CSS module and also apply it to
the div in the code then the CSS Editor
is amazing we can filter any CSS
property if we know what its name is or
we can go down here and do everything
visually like I'll go ahead and make it
a flexbox make it flow vertically set
the Overflow to Hidden and set a Max
width of 300 pixels that's convenient
but it also has some pretty Advanced
tools built into the editor like when it
comes to Shadows the shadow editor
allows you to change all the various
properties which is extremely difficult
and tedious to do in code but now it's
time to make this component interactive
back in the elements panel I'm going to
add another div inside the carousel
along with a couple of buttons inside of
it when pressed these buttons should
rotate between the images in the
carousel we could write all this code in
codex but at this point you may prefer
to switch over to vs code we'll first
destructure the props from our interface
and then use that to interpolate Dynamic
data like the title and the price from
there we can add some State for the
current index of the image that we want
to show in the carousel after which we
can define a couple of functions like
previous image and next image to change
the index in a specific Direction now
let's go ahead and stop there and go
back to codecs if we look at the
component you can now see it's using our
Dynamic data that we created earlier and
if you look in the elements tab you'll
see a gray icon here that tells us it's
an expression or a value computed in the
react.jsx code but one thing we forgot
to do in our code is bind our Carousel
functions to the buttons select a button
from the elements tab then go to the
properties panel and find the on click
property check that box and it will add
an on click event handler to that button
then all we have to do is go down to the
code and add the appropriate function
name then the final step is to update
the default image with the current index
of the images array at this point click
on the eyeball to preview the app here
in codex and it should toggle between
images in the carousel but now that we
have a working component we can put it
to use in other places in the app
application for example if we go back to
the app board we can now drag and drop
our custom component there it shows an
error initially because it's missing the
required props in my full demo I took
some dummy data and looped over it to
show multiple carousels and then styled
them with CSS grid here in codex the
cool thing about this is I can change
the size of the canvas to check its
responsiveness without ever having to
leave the IDE overall codex is a very
new tool and won't replace your main
editor but it has some features that I
think really any developer could take
advantage of whether you're a beginner
or highly experienced but I'm curious to
know what you guys think let me know if
this is a tool you would actually use in
the comments thanks for watching and I
will see you in the next one